um i want to talk about um this town and
i want to tell you about something that
happened to me the other day
um and we're looking at me sad i really
did so um
i don't know if anyone knows but um you
know
so love season two came out you know and
pretty good reaction people really like
it you know i'm feeling good about it
um i i booked a did we talk about a
pilot
yes yes yeah i just got a bit part of
the movie
and so things are good right i mean you
know it's a pretty been a good couple of
months it's been a good week
yeah it just all came in a couple weeks
right so then um
so i met in and out burger the other
night
and i'm sitting there and a korean man
walks up to me i'm not even [ __ ]
kidding you
this guy must have been 55 60 years old
thick accent
are you are you a bubbly
yeah he goes he says in korean like
hello
i go this is respectful and i go hey and
he goes
what happened to you god
i go what i mean you don't my tb
and then you disappear jesus
have money he asked me if i had money
your money you have a job
like what the [ __ ] and he goes render
park
tv show oh my god tv show
you nothing no what if it goes in and
out
and so then i go i wanted to go hey [ __ ]
off man back up
but since he's korean you know and he's
a you know i wanted to like
then i started going into like no
because what happened was i did the road
you know what i mean i'm not gonna
understand the nuances he doesn't know
yeah he's like i don't know
yeah they don't he didn't know and he
literally
literally just brought me down to where
i normally am
of like ah it sucks that's what this
town is though it's just highs and lows
yeah especially with stand up you're
constantly humbled like i did a special
which is fantastic it just came out
yeah and then i did some show with the
virgil where there's
like five people i love them and it was
terrible yeah yeah
virtual does shows i didn't know that i
would just thought it was the placements
but like they do yeah we go there to
drink and dance
i never thought they didn't understand
i posted a photo on instagram with um i
hate it but with james vanderbig just
because i'm doing that show and then
some guy you guys are both half
celebrities
my point is why do that'll always happen
though i know
why i was driving to you know this
podcast and i saw that you guys tweeted
like hey we're gonna have female 1 does
anybody have any questions
and somebody just tweeted nah yeah
hey i tried to delete that right away
all right i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
like yeah it's just hilarious really
they said that
there's no way you could do art in a
large form and have
everybody love you there's gonna be
there was a time
right especially where not everyone had
a voice in the 80s early 90s yeah
like you know you now know what people
from the
forests and the woods and we're so
connected it is very funny i have
youtube comments forwarded to my phone
so sometimes i'll be
about to hit the stage and i'll just get
a message like like [ __ ] you
and then i gotta [ __ ] hit the mic or
like you stink yeah my
question is why because
i mean there are people that you know i
think that are awful i do where i don't
think they have any talent you know and
or whatever i don't know why they made
it but that's just
inside but if i saw them or if i saw a
post of theirs
i wouldn't go hey i [ __ ] hate you
yeah they've got some issues or they've
got their i mean
i'm just saying what is the purpose of
because i know that they're going to
read it
i know that probably or it's going to
affect their day
yeah why would i be a [ __ ] [ __ ] in
that way yeah i wanted to do a show
where we actually like investigate
trolls so we see when they say something
and we go to their work find them you'll
be like why did you it was your thought
process
and you like bust them and then they're
so embarrassed because they have that
that wall of anonymity yeah you take
that away and it's like a 35 year old
dad
yeah and he has to explain why he wrote
some of the dirty content or they don't
have a profile picture
yeah it's just the a and the the name is
some sort of like you know
mystery you know yeah whatever yeah
yeah and then how would you find them
though i'm sure there's
because they probably have the same
username for instagram or something else
i'm sure there's a lot of connections
that's pretty easy to have a digital
footprint
visually digital would you say digital
that was even worse i learned every day
write that down visual v
like vegetables yeah so then you would
then you would knock on the door go to
their work yeah
and go what's up dude you tweeted you
yeah what was going through your head
yeah yeah why'd you write that then just
see them backpedal or stand up to it
that's a great idea if they're
unprepared they're not gonna they're
going to backpedal
you'll be great it's called troll
hunters
yeah that's good dude let's do that
that's why
why why can't you do that i guess we can
do it there's some really good articles
on device when they interview actually
like
like online trolls that make it
like their daily daily part of their
lives there are some really hard core
trolls who are unapologetic
and like this is just my release it's
what i do i find
sheer entertainment from it those are
the hard core trolls that i wouldn't
hunt for
but the dads yeah like the ones yeah
those ones we would hunt for
the ones who actually have something to
lose by being exposed yeah
what if you dress like dog the bounty
hunter
yeah all this equipment yeah this is my
troll net
this is so unnecessary
[Music]
you